cierren los ojos
[Aplausos]
respiren profundo
quiero que se imaginen un loco con una
sierra eléctrica
abran los ojos
quiero que se queden con esta imagen en
su cabeza y ahora les voy a contar una
historia de amor
esta es mi historia de amor con la
locura
todo comienza unos años atrás en río de
janeiro en brasil donde puede participar
en una conferencia que un hombre hablaba
de su primer brote sicótico ese momento
en que su mente se dividió
él contaba esto con tanta emoción
era tan hermoso su relato era tan
poético que yo ingenuamente pensaba
porque no me pasa esto a mí
después voy a aprender que la locura no
es ni tan poética ni tan hermosa todo el
tiempo pero yo ya estaba enamorada
conocí la casa de las palmeras es un
centro que trabaja con personas que
tienen problemas de salud mental graves
especialmente esquizofrenia fundado por
la doctora denise da silveira
este centro trabaja desde la libertad
con el arte desde el afecto
era algo que yo nunca había escuchado
que les pasaba a los locos y me tenía
que ir a conocer
me fui
con un grupo de amigas de compañeras
y ella estaba renato para conocernos
para darnos la bienvenida
renato le estoy nombrando de esa manera
es un hombre mayor que tiene las marcas
del tratamiento psiquiátrico en su
cuerpo es un hombre que le quedan
en este punto poquísimos dientes por
tantos electroshocks que ha recibido sin
anestesia sin relajantes musculares
además tiene dificultad para moverse de
tanto tiempo en aislamiento que ha sido
innecesario
pero estaba ahí el renato para
recibirnos con una gran sonrisa
va caminando por cada uno de los
talleres y el relato estaba atrás no
esto siempre por cada umbral de las
puertas del pasaba de la malla la mano
se pasaba por el pie pasado por el piso
se lamía la mano pasaba por su pie
pasaba por el piso
seguimos
en eso super concentrado de esta visita
yo siento un lengüetazo húmedo baboso
desde el codo hasta el hombro yo me puse
tan feliz yo sabía que era el renato me
doy la vuelta como para agradecerle mis
amigas bueno salieron corriendo hay que
decir estudiantes de psicología por
supuesto salieron corriendo gritando que
porque están locos estos locos sueltos
y para mí fue una bienvenida a un
lengüetazo de bienvenida y desde ahí yo
me quedé ahí el resto de mi formación
fue acompañada por el renato
y él me pudo contar me pudo enseñar un
montón de cosas pero también me enseñó
lo difícil que es estar loco
para que ustedes tengan una idea en el
mundo
5% de la población tiene un problema de
salud mental o sea si nosotros fuésemos
del mundo estamos más o menos 700
personas 35 tienen un problema de salud
mental para que calculen es la primera
fila de este
identifiquen
de estas 35 personas solamente 5 van a
conseguir trabajo
todas las demás no
esto solamente es uno de los problemas
que pasa cuando uno tiene un problema de
salud mental pasa que tenemos una ley en
nuestro país una ley de discapacidades
que fue hecha para facilitar los accesos
para facilitar el ejercicio de derechos
pero la creencia popular es que los
locos son incapaces son impredecibles
son poco confiables
bueno entonces esto se constituye en el
primer estigma para muchas cosas para
conseguir trabajo para enamorarse para
poder seguir estudiando para tener una
vida social se van cerrando caminos un
compañero me contaba
bueno la primera vez que le
diagnosticaron esquizofrenia tuvo su
primer brote psicótico cuando estaba en
la universidad y se fue el psiquiatra y
el psiquiatra le dijo pienso yo que para
causarle alivio le dijo mi hijito no te
preocupes no te preocupes más tú ya no
tienes que estresarte quédate en tu casa
tranquila que no tienes que preocuparte
por estudiar
este compañero después me contaba con
lágrimas que para él ese momento fue una
sentencia
para él fue darse cuenta que le estaba
condenado a vivir el resto de su vida
guardado sin hacer nada porque la vida
convengamos es estresante es frustrante
tiene problemas entonces una
recomendación de quedarse en la casa
tranquilito sin estresarse era una
sentencia de quedarse inmóvil
otro de los estigmas que tienen los
locos es que son peligrosos para esto
agradecemos a hollywood en primer lugar
pero si es que pensamos en un loco
seguro viene y me busca a mí eso no le
va a buscar a uno de ustedes viene me
encuentra a mí me mata no es cierto con
800 puñaladas porque tiene que ser así
de emocionante saca mi corazón se come
escupe y esto siempre alguien va a estar
filmando esto sale en la prensa y
sostiene el estigma
tengo una noticia para darles a ustedes
los locos son mucho menos peligrosos que
el resto de la población no mucho menos
mucho menos peligrosos
más o menos para que tenga una idea esta
primera fila
es él tiene 2% de chance de reincidir
que el resto del público aquí que tiene
70 por ciento de chance de reincidir en
un acto criminal
esto traduzcamos o sea la primera fila
tiene menos chances de matarles al resto
entonces bueno no se asusten no nos
asusten o al menos no todavía
para asustarse hay que hablar del
hospital psiquiátrico del manicomio
el manicomio de este lugar de depósito
de personas donde se quedan estos
renglones torcidos de dios que les decía
torcuato luca de tena
también se llaman instituciones totales
no se llama instituciones totales porque
pasa todo en este espacio todo
amanecemos dormimos hacemos ejercicio y
además es un espacio donde sabemos
exactamente quién tiene el poder por su
ropa o mejor dicho quién no tiene el
poder por cómo está vestido y esos que
tienen el poder les dicen a los otros
que tienen que hacer todo está normado
todo todo todo cuando se respira cuando
se es ejercicio cuando se come cuando se
divierten
todo está normal y todo es predecible
y yo tengo que ser justa porque los
manicomios no fueron creados sino con
buenas intenciones
los manicomios fueron creados con una
intención de curar de tratar y de
proteger no pasa que en el camino nos
perdimos y también surgieron algunos
métodos que se fueron experimentando
como la lobotomía ustedes deben haber
escuchado esto es una práctica que
también se llama lobotomía del picahielo
porque la herramienta que se usa es algo
parecido a un picahielo que se introduce
por el ojo para causar una lesión entre
los dos hemisferios cerebrales y tiene
la intención de separar la comunicación
entre los hemisferios entonces la
persona siente un impulso para hacer
algo pero no puede ejecutarlo
esto evidentemente por el tema del
peligro que tienen los locos
otro método son unas inyecciones de
leche
estas inyecciones de leche son sumamente
dolorosas la leche de un líquido muy
denso
lo que hacen es que causan una fiebre
muy muy alta entonces la persona se
desmaya y cuando se despierta está mejor
todavía no creo que sigue discutiendo si
es que el desmayo era por el dolor estén
ante o por la infección causada
también tenemos el electroshock que yo
les conté que le habían aplicado tantas
veces del relato
consiste en poner unas cargas eléctricas
en el cerebro para causar convulsiones
en el cuerpo lo que sostiene el uso del
electroshock es que no pueden convivir
al mismo tiempo las convulsiones y la
locura
super cortas palabras
en la carga eléctrica tiene que ser tan
potente como para dejar a la persona
convulsionando y después de inconsciente
pero no lo suficiente fue lo
suficientemente fuerte como para que se
muera pero la lógica manicomial esto de
pensar que la cura está en el encierro
en el abandono en el control y el poder
eso se llama lógica manicomial
sabemos que el ejercicio de poder en
estos espacios
solamente causa una cronificación y
mucho abandono las personas se dan un
trabajo enorme cuando una persona se
vuelve loca de meterles en este
manicomio se rompen los lazos se rompen
las conectividades las relaciones los
afectos las habilidades y le vamos a
curar y después cuando está curado
tenemos un trabajo enorme para volver a
llevar a la comunidad para reinsertarlo
no entonces de nuevo recobrar sus
habilidades conexiones afectividad es
por eso tanta gente se queda abandonada
en el hospital psiquiátrico
y creo que todos estos métodos no es
cierto pueden sonar bárbaros pueden ser
muy impresionantes
pero para mí lo más terrible de todo
esto es que puede haber alguien que
quiera hacer esto con otras personas que
quiera tener este ejercicio de poder y
de control sobre otras personas la buena
noticia es que esto ya sabemos que no es
necesario sabemos que no es necesario
que las personas se aparten de su
cotidianidad de estos aspectos de su
vida para poder estar bien mentalmente
no
ha habido suficientes avances en la
medicina en la salud mental comunitaria
que nos dan herramientas para poder
facilitar
y el desarrollo de las personas en su
comunidad
francos bastarle a que es un psiquiatra
italiano que propició la reforma
psiquiátrica en su país él dice y aquí
yo le parafraseó mucho que si la vida
nos vuelve locos la vida también nos
debe sanar
y aquí fíjense que no estamos hablando
más de cura estamos hablando de libertad
y de vida
bueno
pero qué pasa si es que están estos
locos sueltos
ustedes se imaginan
yo les puedo contar un montón de
historias que incluyen algunas un
lengüetazo y otras cosas emocionantes
pero pasa que esta pregunta
de tener los locos sueltos nos da miedo
ustedes se acuerdan la imagen mental del
inicio
cuántos de ustedes levanten la mano se
imaginaron esta
algunos son muy jóvenes por eso no sé no
saben quién es best
yo les quiero contar lo que varios locos
hacen con una sierra eléctrica
[Aplausos]
este es el triángulo de las verduras es
el invernadero de huerto manías huerto
manía es un emprendimiento social que
fue hecho para dar empleo a personas que
tienen problemas de salud mental graves
como esquizofrenia y que han sido
discriminados del mercado laboral por
presupuestos de alrededor de su
condición
este invernadero fue construido por un
equipo de más o menos 30 locos y no sé
cuántos más no declarados y la guía de
arquitectos maravillosos ecuatorianos
el primer día que estábamos ya listos
para hacer todo esto se me acerca el
arquitecto y me dice oye y me y como
hacemos
con como como hacemos el tipo no sabe
hacer un invernadero nos traigan
como como hace más
y me dicen no es que yo nunca he
trabajado con personas que tengan un
diagnóstico psiquiátrico
bueno ahí yo fue un baldazo porque yo no
había pensado en esto
entonces me acuerdo que soy psicóloga y
le devuelvo la pregunta tú qué piensas
que usted tiene que hacer
y él me dice bueno la primera
normalmente lo que yo hago es que la
primera yo le enseño hacer la segunda le
acompaño haciendo y la tercera hace solo
dije bueno tenemos que hacer lo mismo
porque teníamos un montón de gente sin
ninguna experiencia previa construyendo
con sierras eléctricas sirve circulares
amoladora que yo ni sabía que era
taladros industriales en altura de 6 y 8
metros pero lo logramos y cuando
terminamos después de tres días de
trabajar de 8 de la mañana hasta las 10
de la noche un trabajo extenuante
estábamos con xavi sí mos mirando para
abajo a nuestra obra de arte
y les pregunto a mis compañeros bueno
qué les pareció
y aquí hubo un silencio que casi me
muero debe haber sido unos diez segundos
para mí fueron como diez minutos que
dije dios mío les causó un trauma
permanente irreversible no
que como me meto a hacer esto
hasta que alguien finalmente
suspiro
y dijo y yo hice esto
y después de eso no hubo vuelta atrás
porque se trata de eso hablamos de
derechos humanos del derecho a sentirse
productivos a sentirse útiles a tener un
espacio donde nuestras habilidades se
puedan desarrollar a tener las
herramientas esa sierra eléctrica que
nos permita demostrar nuestras
habilidades y ponerlas al servicio de
otras personas
porque de lo que se trata es que a todos
nos puede pasar esto no le pasa a esos
que están ahí adentro en el hospital en
esos muros y que no les vemos a esos
otros esto nos puede pasar a todos
esto se trata de que todos necesitamos
lo mismo
todos necesitamos a alguien que ha
puesto en nosotros en quien nosotros
apostar necesitamos a alguien que
reconozca que somos capaces pero
nosotros también comernos del cuento
todos necesitamos también sentirnos
fracasados y sentirnos fáciles y poder
seguir aprendiendo
ahora esto es una historia de amor pero
no es posible romantizar la locura es
difícil es sufrida y hay muchos muchas
barreras de acceso muchos problemas pero
entonces es necesario hacer algo al
respecto
yo he escogido esta historia de amor mi
historia de amor sigue y yo he escogido
que mi camino es por el triángulo de las
verduras
todos debemos buscar el camino la
doctora ni se da silveira ya lo dijo la
locura está profundamente ligada al
desamor
por lo tanto es necesario de amor para
poder salvar a alguien de la locura
y quien no necesita eso
[Aplausos]